yeah we was we've been rocking since
then get her though was one of them ones
too for Shelly shout out to Tiger shout
out my [ __ ] that was like uh that like
whole era of like 98 BPM ratchet songs
yeah it's just tiger somehow made his
way on every single remix
[Laughter]
I was just like I was just talking to
Joe Moses I'm like damn tiger was on do
it for the ratchets remix get her though
God damn this [ __ ] was jumping
on every he's like you're gonna play
Rack City and then you're gonna play the
remixes of all the songs that I that
aren't mine that I'm on yeah for real
good timing just west coast clubs yeah I
was having a hell of fun yeah we just
especially coming up this way and I wish
people would make that like I feel like
there's like a lack of that kind of [ __ ]
in the club right now like I don't feel
like La artists or Bayer artists are
making like those records right now yeah
they know Turnt Up
sounds right it's like missing low-key
like there's like some [ __ ] like pilo's
doing a good job of making [ __ ] that you
know is cool but like I feel like I
don't know man like the Stoneman record
is cool I just mean like this ain't no
more ratchet the ratchet [ __ ] like the
[ __ ] that the business you know what I
do you feel me I got something coming
right now that's gonna turn all that up
good I promise you that's good two I got
two big features on it uh y'all I'll see
real soon I'm announcing real soon the
song been done you feel me uh we working
on the video right now and uh this
[ __ ] gonna wake up all the clubs
strip clubs okay that's what's missing
yeah and that's what's crazy is because
like Tyga's been like uh putting out
records that uh have been less than
favorable in my opinion and I'm just
like let's not overthink this tiger put
out some [ __ ] talking about can we get
some more of that YG same shot like YG
where's the [ __ ] ratchet
where's the ratchet [ __ ] just give me
one of them give me one like uh Mozzy
put a record out with YG on the hook
call put it in my face that was
reminiscent of those hearts yeah I was
like okay this is this I like this one